if I was you and one of the mantle
meghan trainor speaks out about her
photoshop scandal admitting to ET that
she was shocked by the reaction she
received from fans about her altered me
to music video i really it was so
embarrassed I didn't I thought they
would attack me like she's photoshopping
she can't be doing that and I they were
just routed me on there every was so
kind the singer exclusively revealed to
ET that she initially approved the
altered music video but later requested
it be removed from YouTube due to her
noticeably photoshopped waist for me
when I happened I was like and I wear
enough space so I don't need to be cut
in half you know it and it's just not
who I am and I don't want to promote
that and so I even if it means take down
the video and shock the world for a
minute what is it like for you to have
that power that you can call the VEVO
god I felt pretty badass I'm not gonna
lie about pretty cool I I said I felt
like I was calling the gods of you gah I
said get this down as fast as you can
and they thank you to my team they
really delivered they got that down in
minutes
I couldn't believe Draenor also opened
up about taking a tumble on The Tonight
Show admitting she chose to keep her
embarrassing fall in the final take
there's an opportunity to get up and
redo it but I tried I got up and I redid
it at first time I came on I was like ah
yeah guys I fell and they all you got
that you have Jimmy Fallon laying down
with you and you're like and that's what
I went to the editing booth and I was
like you're right let's keep it it looks
great then you know what it goes with
the lyrics I look fine keep the ball